I'm curious because there's got to be
some
uh you know you've you've you're so in
touch with who you were uh maybe how
insecure or you were as a kid and then
um you completely
transform your body and that's got to
release all kinds of
Revelations you know what I mean just in
terms of
uh okay this is something that wouldn't
have seemed possible to me when I was a
nine-year-old and this never felt like
it was a possibility and then I always
think great wisdom comes from having
your dream come true and not always the
not always the best you know I mean it's
always a mixed bag it's not all bad it's
not all good but yeah
I I feel one what I knew I always had
was determination and so there was a
point where I was like all right I'm
just gonna like change how I look for
this thing now
what it weirdly did was you know as a
kid I had the until I was like seven or
six I was the cutest kid you'd ever seen
I was adorable and I knew it like if I
walked into a store
I knew it because you had those muscles
back then yeah it was a buff little kid
yeah yeah uh it's so funny that you it's
so funny you say you knew it like you
would walk up to adults and go are you
ready to meet a cutie pie I wouldn't
have to I was so cute that shopkeepers
were threatening to kidnap me wow so I
was the ultimate compliment very well
oh you're kidnappable it really like
literally all the time like as I walked
in the store and I didn't get a
compliment I'd be like what is wrong
with these people wow you should see
pictures of of me like until I was six
or seven I was adorable
and then it really changed very quickly
my neck got really long I got four
Adam's apples my head got huge my body
was never a reactor
yeah there may be an explanation here
yeah my both eyes formed joined and
formed one eye
uh and I got cancer I should have
mentioned but also but also heat vision
but yeah yeah I mean it all it all
balances out the worst of the powers
um right you're right yeah you have a
microwave yeah we have a microwave yeah
the most useless power there is I can
heat up coffee slightly
it doesn't work that well it's more of a
warming Ray
that'd be great a superhero who could
make things slightly warmer right would
you like me to no no we're good we have
a microwave okay
yeah how's your soup is it a slightly
cold no yeah my soup's fine I can bring
it up to slightly above room too it's
really good it's fine thank you
um and uh it's supposed to be a little
cool
yeah yeah my weakness is gazpacho
Dr gazpacho
versus slightly warm guy
and my body stayed tiny like my
shoulders stayed tiny they used to call
me chicken shoulders at school that's a
very uh descriptive and just specific
put down right I don't even think of a
chicken having sugar exactly exactly
they were so good at it wow yeah and who
goes to a KFC and orders the chicken
shoulders nobody do you like a bucket of
chicken shoulders they have no shoulders
oh no it's off menu like yeah
that's why their sweaters fall off
anyway
come on we're having a good time no
one's getting hurt you ever seen the
chicken and suspenders
where do you see a chicken shrug yeah
when you see a chicken opening a present
at Christmas and it's suspenders and he
goes
like what am I gonna [ __ ] do with it
okay we're putting it into this riff his
shoulder riff is needs to end yeah in 10
minutes keep going
but so okay so uh so so I and and it
took me I remember when I dawned on me I
was like you know nobody's threatened to
kidnap me in a while I wonder what's
going on and then looking in the mirror
being like Oh no huge nose uh they also
called me eggplant nose so they had a
few little different like poultry
vegetable based yeah they seem hungry
they're very hungry they were I mean you
know it's Pakistan we're hungry
um and so I sort of became very
um obsessed with how I looked from the
age of like 10 to really my early 20s
um and so and then I sort of in my 20s
doing work to be like you know it
doesn't matter how you look that's kind
of why comedy was so important to me
where it doesn't matter how you look
right I remember I was doing a show
early on I won't say who it is but I was
with a handsome guy and I came back and
I like gained some weight and he like
made fun of me and I was like
um I can look like anything and work
just as much as I work now you need to
look like that to work right uh and I
remember feeling very proud of myself
because I could see it hurt his feelings
um uh and and and so then doing the work
and not worrying about it as much and
then later again to sort of get in this
kind of shape and worrying about how I
looked again it was kind of a mind [ __ ]
it sort of it felt like I'd like
regressed 10 years back to to how it was
and then and then now I think I have a
good relationship with it because
the working out you know you were saying
not being in the moment when I work out
I feel in the moment because you're
lifting heavy weight
and you kind of need to be there and
focus on that you have to be outside
yourself you have to make sure
you're using it properly otherwise
you're gonna get hurt so I get really a
lot out of it my anxiety has been a lot
lower I sleep a lot better since I've
been like working out a bunch and it
probably changes your diet too I would
think it does and it made me realize how
how things made me make me feel when I'm
eating them so like now I know you know
I can eat this donut and it's gonna feel
great for you know 90 seconds because we
eat fast
um but for the next two hours my energy
is going to be weird I'm going to feel
bloated like I'm gonna feel low energy
so so now I'm aware of how things make
me feel that's the biggest thing I
wasn't aware of any of these things
until uh I met Liza and Liza's just
naturally very healthy I mean the first
time I
you know when we were first dating I
stopped by her apartment and was going
to take her out and I said did you want
to get some food and she said oh no I I
ate already and she had this you know
tiny tiny tiny apartment
with like a little piece of a kitchen
this little fragment of a kitchen and I
said you ate already and I I didn't see
any pans or you know if if I had it's in
the same situation if I had told someone
I just ate they'd have been like a ham
carcass in the corner
and uh through the three empty boxes of
cocoa Crispies uh
um but there was not and I said hey what
did you eat and she said oh no I'm fine
I had
um some almonds and uh I had some dates
and then I had you know some tea and I'm
all ready to go and I thought what are
you you're ins you're an insane person
let me ask does she enjoy food loves it
loves it and eats it and eats very uh
healthy things but that's just and then
I met her people and her people are just
they have they have something that might
be agents and lawyers
yes yes like her parents and her family
they're all they they're sensible they
eat a they eat sensible Foods in
sensible quantities and I thought I ca
I've never been seen this before I come
from crazed Irish hillbillies that just
you know uh no one's sensibly eating a
sensible amount of food and then saying
that's enough we're all eating our
feelings because we can't talk about
other things right and um so if you're
eating you don't have to talk to them
yeah and you don't have to talk about
things that might be complicated you can
just I'll show you
you know I'll swallow all this food and
then go take a nap and then my feelings
will just be excreted along with the
fruit
come on but did I go too far yeah yeah
you start getting into poop yeah did I
say poop yeah excreted yeah it could be
uh through perspiration no you implied
you were [ __ ] out your sadness I
certainly did
I certainly did I also come from my
toilet said to me once you've got a lot
of stuff to unpack
and I said hey
sentient toilet
no but um yeah I I guess I did uh but I
I you know since then I'm now do I think
about those things which is a huge
change for me I I think about how is
this going to make me feel yeah so I'm
doing better at that but I still the day
that I can divide my plate in half and
slowly eat half and not eat the other
half I don't think that's happening in
my lifetime not this day
um yeah my family is the same the you
eat as much as you possibly can partly
because Pakistani food is amazing and my
mom is now the best cook I know
um
and when we visit it's the same thing
Emily's like your parents are just
always forcing you to eat forcing me to
eat we eat as much as possible but now
as they've gotten older and started
having you know everyone in my family
dies of a heart attack everybody does
um on principle yeah we hold out okay
like if we get the cool kids yeah if we
get cancer or something we start eating
butter and and running in bad ways
um what age do they get the heart attack
usually because this is important yes so
my grandmother passed away at the age of
40 of us oh my God which is very very
young uh my dad uh has had like he had
like an eight bypass thing which is
really huge but what I'm very proud of
for them is they've really gotten it
together they both eat very very healthy
now
um they've changed their diet completely
they still eat Pakistani food but now
you know it's vegetables it's not as
much rice not as much carbs they eat no
sugar so I'm very proud of them for the
changes that they've made in their lives
it's hard because there's also like
cultural pressure to not do it oh of
course I mean I think you talk about
Pakistani food I think about
um the food that Irish immigrants you
know or immigrant culture it was always
a meat potato lots of butter lots of you
know and um uh lots of dairy lots of
bread and uh and and every meal was was
was some version of that yeah and and I
think it's so cultural it's also
cultural we come from this and then it's
been around for
in some version or another for hundreds
of years because it's only a recent
luxury that people could say I should
start thinking about what I of course it
used to be if you can find something to
eat yeah get it into you right and you
get to live yes exactly now and that is
our you know our evolutionary mandate
yes uh is is to eat and have sex with
anyone who will have sex that's why we
love donuts and [ __ ] yeah
man there's my bio that's the title of
my bio donuts and [ __ ] Conan O'Brien
story
shockingly uh no one has purchased
Conan's book
in many countries in many countries
where the content is
interesting but the title alone has
turned everyone off yeah
donuts and [ __ ]
and you know what sometimes people don't
even have to hear who wrote the book
they just go there's a book out called
donuts and [ __ ] Conan O'Brien wrote a
book